IRL will be live in Miami with Patrick
Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt Gates and
Luke rowski join us there get your
tickets by clicking the link in the
description below or by going to
timcast.net official quote Russia has
already won White House media are lying
about Ukraine the explosive claim was
made in the latest bombshell report
published on September 21st by poer priz
winning investigator reporter Seymour
hirs who spoke with an official who has
access to current intelligence
intelligence about the conflict the war
is over Russia's one I read that quote
already according to her's report the
war is continuing because Ukrainian
President Vladimir zinski insists that
it must currently there is no discussion
at zelinsky's headquarters or at the
White House about a ceasefire and no
interest in discussions that could lead
to an end of the conflict so I suppose
we could just say right now seor is
wrong and his source is bad but I'm
curious what you guys think about where
we're what's currently going on and
where we are with Ukraine and you were
going to make a point before I ENT
interrupted you uh about uh uh the war
in Ukraine ah so so yeah the reason why
um yeah got to see H second but the
reason why he's using the language of
climate change and the reason why they
now have a trans person as a military
spokesperson that's going well had uh he
was he was put on leave oh he was okay
uh CU he stole some of his luggage no no
he said that everyone who spoke out
against the government needed to be
jailed and then they went and arrested
gon Gonzalo Lera and uh have been
Gonzalo reported torturing him yeah they
were threatening that anyone that spoke
poorly of Ukraine would be facing like
justice and it's like are you
threatening US citizens that spoke out
against Ukraine and so that person
torturing one right now so a couple days
ago they were put on leave I don't know
much more about it that's what I heard
anyway sorry to interrupt no just saying
that they look they know they know that
they are um look where's their bread
buttered it's bid Administration y all
he hears Biden saying is climate climate
change climate change so hey hell why
don't I make climate change the issue
here and I'll get even more support it's
really low brow a really pathetic
attempt to manipulate I'm very concerned
about you know it may be pathetic but I
think it works I think the left looks at
that and go oh he's for he CL it's a
signal what he's saying to the the elite
left is I'm willing to read the script
it's a signal to them that I'm your boy
I'll read this what you climate change
transs what's the next thing you guys
need just keep the money flowing these
are all signals for that That explicit
purpose and I'm not going to get into
like who's winning or losing the war cuz
I'm on the armed services committee and
don't want to reflect on anything
classic
but I I think we can look at Afghanistan
and we can look at what's going on here
and say what a lot of these defense
contractors are pushing toward is how to
have an extended kind of low yield War
like if there's a way to turn stretch
this thing out turn it into a 20 30y
year kind of thing where there's a whole
lot of money moving around and
unaccountable pots and a lot of weapons
getting bought and then oh man the stock
piles well we got to spend more money to
reload those I think that the reason we
are as involved in Ukraine as we are is
because Afghanistan wound down and if we
still had Afghanistan to launder money
through there probably wouldn't be the
need for this type of excessive
involvement in Ukraine dude I would love
to alter our weapons program to create
just a drone defense program where we go
up into space and low orbit and we just
build billions of drones that we blow up
and we give the defense companies all
this money even more money than they're
making now to blow up machines instead
of humans and then we could work with
Russia that rant from me and Crossland
was brought to you by let me take my let
me take my jacket off CU I know we're
going two onone here and I'm good two on
one yeah I know we we're going to be
both of you against me that's fine what
about him three on one I'm an innocent
sideliner what are you thinking I I I
well the idea that we would just give
money the military industrial complex to
appease them to Abate them because they
do bad things it's kind of like it's a
parasite in my brain and I don't know
how to get rid of without killing myself
so I don't want to kill myself uh and I
admit that military is a big part of our
the ethos of the United States I mean
we're a militaristic country t on your
foot keep it away from your pancas I
just want to remind you the language
we're using and look it's okay but it's
the language the left right left has
always been the ones talk about the
military-industrial complex and that's
what runs our country and and I'm not
saying
you're I'm not saying you can't say it
just because great leftist thinker
Dwight de Eisenhower but I think they
were I think the left 10 13 years ago
was right about a whole lot they
supported Julian Assange now all of a
sudden they're in line with Amazon
Walmart and major corporations be for
free speech and they oppose government
surveillance
and now they're in favor of censorship
yeah it's the military used to be racist
now they're for NATO expansion they used
to be opposed to defunding the police
and all sudden start using it against
Republicans I drank with Julian ass
Sange while I was under house arrest in
London oh wow oh what did you drink
Scotch single M Blended what what am I a
trite of course I was single Mall okay
just checking I us I think I I I look at
this report it's funny that this timcast
just published this it's I believe
Adrian Adrien Norman was reporting on it
cuz uh I said this a little while ago
and we were talking downstairs before
the show I was talking to Amy and I said
so we have this map from the BBC and you
can look at February 22 uh
2022 you've got separatist back donbass
and then you have Crimea under Russian
control and then by June 2023 Russia
controls the entire land bridge into
Crimea and so they they they won they
seize the territory they wanted to gain
control and more access to their their
their uh uh warm water port in the in
the Black Sea and their access to the
med Mediterranean that's first of all
Seymour hirs is not a credible Source
right I mean some sometimes something he
says is credible you don't buy you don't
buy the bin Laden Seymour hirs story no
okay not an argument though so so I
could say understand the New York Times
insert all the wrong things everything
that was wrong about all the military
stuff but I agree with you we don't have
to just blindly agree this story is true
so I'm looking I only look at this
through the prism of what's good for the
United States ultimately right what is
good in our what is in our national
interest it is in our national interest
to continue to degrade the the Russian
military taking Russia off the
geopolitical board which is what we are
in the process of doing and taking them
off that board for 25 or 30 years is in
our national interest to destroy them
economically by losing their entire
European access to the gas market is in
our economic interest and even more than
that what's our what's really in our
interest taking Taiwan off the table in
terms of Russ of Chin's Invasion and I'm
telling you this is what we've done
China has looked at Ukraine
understanding it is not in the US
national interest anywhere close to what
Taiwan is and we went to bat for Ukraine
they understand that if they invade
Taiwan they are
screwed they will not invade Taiwan for
the next 25 years they technically did
several but like we're talking about
land Invasion because four days ago
we've had Jerusalem Post saying China
invades Taiwanese air airspace with 20
military aircraft a week before that
there were something like 60 different
ships they're flying sorties over Taiwan
all the time so that answer would
absolutely get an A at the Georgetown
School of Foreign Service right that
that is the that is the answer that we
hear most frequently so I want to take
some of those arguments first that we
have to take Russia off the geopolitical
landscape so since the invasion they
have actually got more relationships in
Africa not less Putin just hosted this
big African Summit where they all came
to Moscow and he was able to make even
even more audacious claims of support
and Grain and by taking you know by
taking Ukraine out of the distribution
of some of that grain he's stepping in
to fill it so in a way the war in
Ukraine is allowing him to project more
power in
Africa please please who that that the
argument the a who cares by the way I
care way more about the Essential
Elements and The Rare Earth elements
that drive the entire global economy
that exists in Africa than I care about
some oil rigs in the dumbass reg rare
you know the Rare Earth elements aren't
rare we can we can M them and they're in
Alaska they can M them here but we
because because of Biden but what but
what's more geopolitically important the
dbas or Africa no what do I care more
it's not about dbas what do I care more
about about Africa we have driven Sweden
and Norway into NATO which they didn't
do for decades and decades that's what
we've done now now we now we've provided
we've extended the security guarantee to
two more countries two two two more two
more very stable countries who by the
way are an absolute interest to defend
by the way I am not for Ukraine being
part of NATO I'm not for Ukraine being
part of the EU for those Reasons I'm not
looking to have I do not want to have
any I don't want a US troop in Ukraine
and I wouldn't support anything that
would contractually obligate us to do
that but for Sweden Norway to have them
come to Nato is a huge win for us
because there are two more countries
that now are are are protectorates of
the United States there two more people
that that that that have armies that
that supp well let's see when they
actually meet the requirements on their
military spending and and and and by the
way we this is also helped put yeah look
I again I agree completely I think it is
a is an embarrassment that they haven't
and I think we should and I think I'm
glad and by the way they increased their
they increased their spending because of
Trump trump pushed the increase of
spending because he said we'll pull out
and they said whoa but by the way they
have spent more money on Ukraine than we
have I'm glad that at least Sweden and
Norway have spent more money on Ukraine
than we have all of Europe okay well you
know since Ukraine's in Europe it seems
reasonable okay but I'm saying is they
we have now found a way to get them to
spend more money on the military think
they realized we all it cost us was 118
billion that's a you know what is that
all it is so far 118 I thought it was
more that's all we got on paper yeah I
mean you know seems Seems like a lot to
me I I also want to address the Taiwan
argument because I think the major
geopolitical objective we ought to have
is to stop a fusion of China and Russia
the the Sino Russian Alliance poses a
greater threat to us than almost
anything and through our involvement in
this war we have driven Russia into the
arms of China you look at a lot of the
Farmland in eastern Russia it is getting
bought literally bought by the Chinese
you're seeing a leveraged buyout of
Russia through China that is making them
stronger and I don't think that she
views dbas and Ukraine as in any way
like comparable tactically to the home
game that they get to play in Taiwan I
mean it's not a surprise to anyone that
when we war game out a CH a Taiwan
conflict China wins every time why
because our f-35s don't get into the
fight our loral combat ship gets blown
up before they even get there and we run
out of torpedoes that's what happens in
every in every war game and I don't know
that that type of a like Maritime
amphibious assault is comparable to
Putin running some broken tanks into
into Ukraine and when it comes to
degrading the Russian military I worry
more about Russia's nuclear weapons than
I worry about what tanks and armored
divisions they have rolling around the
planes of Europe I don't think my I
don't think my constituents are
fundamentally impacted based on which
guy in a tracksuit is in charge of
Crimea yeah I do think they're impacted
if we are like poking the nuclear bear
and I and I do believe that uh it is
well within within the capabilities of
Putin to use nuclear weapons I am not
saying mves or you know the Satan 2
missile they call it I'm talking about
you know 100 kiloton nuclear artillery
things like that being launched into
Battlefield why why do you take the Ming
armaments off the table so oh I'm not
I'm saying the first thing we should we
should be concerned about is in the
active theater in eastern Ukraine a
false flag no no I'm saying don't yes
that's a big factor as well but uh
honestly there's a good argument to be
made that it is more reasonable that
Ukraine would false flag a nuclear
strike to blame Russia but there's also
very good reasons for Russia if they
want to expand their territory Beyond
just the land bridge why why do you
think they would do that why would
Russia use no no why you think you I
mean look I'm not I I don't know I'm not
into the mind of the ukrainians I'll
give you it's really simple if you're
Ukrainian if you you zalinski do you
want to lose the
war no no of course not uh do you are
are in what position are you right now
well as you already pointed out you're
actively trying to convince Americans to
keep footing the bill and you know
Republicans are off the table so you're
playing the Democrat game we're not
republicans in Congress well sure sure
they're the lagging indicator you know
that the the the the the the the
American population and the way the Maga
base operates that you're not going to
be be pandering to them although they
probably should be so let's think about
what it means to actually win a war does
it make sense if you are say like a a
Waring there's feudal Lords Waring in
Japan and they're like you know I got to
take out my Ral let's walk to his front
Gates and then fight his guards or does
it make more sense to have a ninja
dressed like a maiden or or a servant go
in in the middle of the night take out
the emperor and then flee by running out
the back door thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net MERS only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next
time